hi this is presh talwalkar
there's an interesting pattern if you
multiply a number that has only ones by
itself
if you multiply a number that has five
ones in it by itself
you'll count up to the number five in
order and then you count back down to
one to create a palindrome of the
numbers in ascending and then descending
order
this pattern will continue
for example if you want to multiply a
number which has nine ones by itself you
would count up one two three four five
six seven eight nine and then you would
count down eight seven six five four
three two one
but what happens when you have a number
which has ten ones how would you
multiply that by itself
if the pattern continues you would count
up to 10 and then you count back down to
1.
if you had a number with 11 ones in it
you would count up to 11 and then you
count back down to one
in this video i'm going to show you a
very real way in which this pattern does
continue and you could say this is an
accurate representation of the
multiplication
but since we write numbers in decimal
form we're going to want to carry over
whenever we have a result that's more
than 10.
so when we have 10 ones in the digit our
actual result on a calculator will be
slightly different
and the same thing happens for any
number when we have more than 10 ones in
the digit i'm going to show you how you
can actually get to these results even
though the pattern continues
so to show you how this pattern works
i'm going to use a method of multiplying
numbers by using lines
i've provided a link in the video
description for that and you can check
out the method i'm going to give you a
brief explanation
so let's say you want to multiply 11 by
itself
for the number 11 we're going to draw
one line for each digit in the number so
for the leading one we draw one line and
then for the one in the units digit we
draw another line
for the other number that we're
multiplying by we we're going to draw
lines in the opposite direction
so for this one we're going to draw one
line in the opposite direction
and for the other one we're going to
draw another line
to get our results we're going to count
out the number of intersections between
the lines
on the very far right we look at the
vertically lined intersections and we
have one
in the middle these two intersections
are vertically aligned so we have two
intersections
and finally on the far left we have one
intersection
so a result of 11 times 11 is 121.
so now we're going to try and extend
this pattern
so to do that i'm going to redraw this
diagram a little bit i'm going to bring
in these lines
and we're going to have exactly the same
diagram that's smooshed in just a little
bit we still have 1 2 and one as a
result of eleven times eleven
and the reason i'm doing this is now we
wanna extend the pattern
let's say we wanna multiply
a hundred and eleven
we're going to add one more line
and if we change the second number to
111 we're going to add one more line
again
so what have we done in this new figure
where we're multiplying
111 by itself
which intersections have we created
which are new well we created one
intersection on the far left
then we've added one intersection to
each of the columns that we've already
had
and then on the far right we have one
more intersection
so when we count up the vertically
aligned intersections we're going to
start out with one on the far right
then we have two
then we have three
we again have two and then we have one
so you can see why we have a very
symmetrical pattern of intersections
and you can also see that we're adding
one intersection to each of the existing
numbers and then we're adding one on the
far left and the far right
so 111 times itself
is one two three two one
in fact this pattern continues i'm going
to show you one more example
so let's say we wanted to extend this to
add the number one to each of the
numbers we already have
so we want one thousand a hundred and
eleven we're going to draw one more line
for that and for one thousand hundred
eleven and the second number we do the
same thing so we draw one line for our
first number and one line for our second
number
now in order to use multiplying by lines
we're going to extend the lines we
already have
so that we create the intersections
and we end up with another lattice grid
so which are the new intersections we've
created by adding one to each number
well you can see on the far left we've
started out with one intersection so
that's the one which begins our new
multiplication product
we're going to add one to each of the
columns which we've already had in our
previous result and then finally on the
far right we add one more
so we count up the vertically line
intersections we end up with one two
three four three 2 1.
so you can see how this pattern
continues if you wanted to add a fifth
number one
multiplying it by itself you're going to
add one more line on the left one more
line on the right and it's going to
increase each of the existing columns by
one and then we're going to add 1 on
each end so that's why this pattern
continues where we have palindromic
numbers that go up in increasing order
counting up the numbers and then
counting down
so that explains how we get up all the
way to nine
now when we get to 10
you're going to see visually that this
pattern will continue if you were to
draw out that lattice grid multiplying
by lines you would see that you would
end up with one column that had 10
intersections
so if you represented numbers in this
way you actually could argue the pattern
would continue
but since in decimal form we never have
a numerical digit that's more than 9
we're going to need to use carryover so
the column which has 10 is actually
going to become 0 that's going to carry
over to the left so that the column
which has 9 will then become 10.
we're going to carry that over once more
so that the column which has eight
becomes nine
so we're going to end up with results
one two three four five six seven all
that's none of that's affected that
eight needs to become a nine
the next two digits will become zero
because we have carry over
and then on the far right we're still
gonna have nine eight seven six five
four three two one
that's still the same
so similarly if you have a number which
has eleven ones you actually would have
multiplying by lines a diagram that goes
up one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven ten nine eight
seven six five four three two one
in order to get a number which would
match with the result on your calculator
we're going to need to use carry over
any time we have a value more than nine
so we're going to need to carry over the
10 the 11 the 10
and we're going to create
this is not too difficult for you to use
carryover
you would end up with another pattern we
go one two three five six seven
9 and then we have 0 1 2 0 and then we
go 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1. so you could use
this method
to calculate multiplying any number
which has just ones by itself
so it's a kind of interesting way to see
why
when you multiply a number just with
ones by itself you end up with this
interesting pattern of palindromes
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
provided links in the video description